[Applause]
it would be curious if this category was
for best performance by an actress in an
opposing role
and yet the the brilliant work of these
five superb actresses reminded me that
with a child or with an adult sometimes
the most supportive thing is to oppose
oppositions great in films and stories
it's wonderful in sports who wants a
weak opponent in a sports match it's
really good in society
the thing these films made me remember
and think about was the difficulty
something that women seem to be better
at than men of opposing without hatred
so here are the nominees for performance
by an actress in a supporting role
Viola Davis fences
Naomi Harris moonlight
Nicole Kidman lion
[Applause]
Octavia Spencer hidden figures
Michelle Williams Manchester by the sea
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Viola Davis
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and third
nomination for Biola Davis she was
previously nominated in this category
for doubt and for her leading role in
the health
[Music]
foreign
thank you to the academy
you know there's one place
that all the people with the greatest
potential are gathered
one place
and that's the graveyard
people ask me all the time
what kind of stories
do you want to tell viola
and I say exhume those bodies
exhume those stories
the stories of the people who dreamed
big
and never saw those dreams to fruition
people who fell in love and lost
I became an artist and thank God I did
because we are the only profession that
celebrates what it means to live a life
foreign
who exhumed and exalted The Ordinary
People
and to Braun picture his Paramount macro
Todd Black Molly Allen Scott Rudin for
being
the cheerleaders
for a movie that is about people
and words
and life and forgiveness and Grace
and to Michael T Williamson Stephen
McKinley Henderson Russell Hornsby
Giovanna deposaniah Cindy for being
the most wonderful artist I've ever
worked with
and Oh Captain My Captain Denzel
Washington
[Applause]
thank you for putting two entities in
the driving seat August and God
and they served you well
and to Dan
and may Alice Davis who were this and
are the Center of My Universe
the people who taught me good or bad how
to fail how to love how to hold the Lord
how to lose
my parents
I'm so thankful that God chose you
bring me into this world to my sisters
my sister Dolores who's here who played
jaji and Jaja with me we were rich white
women in the tea party games
thank you
thank you for the imagination
and to my husband and my daughter
my heart
you and Genesis you teach me every day
how to live how to love I'm so glad that
you are the foundation of my life
thank you to the academy thank you
[Applause]